Do you have friends who are climate science
deniers? Well slap a smile on that face and
listen up, because we're here to help you
school 'em.
[MUSIC]
Hey y'all, Trace here for DNews with all the
ammunition you need when someone cites the
severe winter we've had this year as the reason
there's no such thing as global warming. The
most important thing to get across, is TODAY
doesn't mean a load of bantha crap. It's TRENDS
that matter. CLIMATE is weather over time,
and as time marches on, the climate has changed,
thus CLIMATE CHANGE. That change happens to
be a warming trend and thus why they call
it GLOBAL WARMING. Again, the WEATHER happening
TODAY doesn't tell us what's happened over
the last several dozen years. Though earlier
this year it was colder in Manitoba, Canada
than it was on MARS -- in Australia they're
getting the hottest temperatures ever! In
the same year, at the same time. So, rather
than quoting anecdotes and laughing, bring
the data.
According to the University Corporation for
Atmospheric Research, we're experiencing more
record highs than ever before, indicating
we're on a warming trend. Not to mention the
overall global temperature, which is currently
a balmy 57.9 degrees Fahrenheit (14.4 C) making
this year, globally, the eighth hottest year
on record, ALL of which have been since 1998.
Again, it's getting hotter.
That alone might not convince a lot of people,
because most will hit back with disagreements
among scientists. This is when you mention
Albuquerque. From 1991 to 2012 there were
nearly 14,000 peer-reviewed published scientific
papers exploring climate science. 24 of those
said global warming is fake. To put it in
perspective, that's like saying every person
in the United States agrees with climate change,
except the population of Albuquerque. Silly
Albuquerque. If a movie had 98-percent approval,
would you go see it? There are more people
who hated Wall-E than there are climate scientists
denying climate change. Have you EVER met
someone who hates Wall-E?! Me either.
Keep smiling during your friend's talking
about how climate is cyclical, and we can't
possibly know because we weren't there. At
this point, you can throw them off by agreeing.
Because they're right, climate IS cyclical.
100 million years ago the tropics stretched
from Alaska to Antarctica, then it cooled.
55 million years ago, it was hot again; temperatures
rose by 6 degrees celsius in 20,000 years
because of massive methane release -- then
it cooled again. And finally, a report by
NASA from 2012 says 20 million years ago,
Antarctica had trees, and then it cooled.
All this is absolutely true. We're on a cycle
of boom and bust, like in economics, but based
on the study of fossil evidence, corroborated
by ice cores from Antarctica, the boom of
heat we're getting now is WAY faster than
it should be. Normally, barring an asteroid
impact, major volcanic ash cloud, or some
other global disaster this cycle is millions
of years long... So really, they're proving
your point, because we just came out of an
ice age 60,000 years ago, and unlike a slow
plodding increase in temperature -- in THIS
warming, the heating has sped up in the last
100 years.
Finally, while your worthy opponent reels
from you showing them how their own evidence
supports your claims, make sure you mention
global warming isn't REALLY the best term.
It's climate change. Because we have to look
at these changes over lifetimes, and while
YES the globe is warming -- it's ALSO going
to cool off, causing more snow, more ice,
more drought, and, generally, more extreme
weather. Some lawmakers are pushing to change
the term to "global climate disruption," but
that's just a title. The important thing is,
no one hates Wall-E, but until we learn to
work with nature, no one wants to live on
his planet either.
What do you think? Let me know your thoughts
on our Facebook, Twitter and GooglePlus or
leave a comment below! Thanks for watching
DNews today subscribe and, stay cool out there.